mais où on l'a vu cette semaine - 3 %
sur un wall street les marchés canadiens
qui sont ébranlés aussi les signaux de
la bourse ne sont pas rassurants les
tensions commerciales entre washington
et pékin sont toujours vives
est ce qu'on doit craindre une récession
mondiale on commence à en parler
sérieusement en tout cas depuis mercredi
entre autres à mes côtés pour faire le
point hendrix vachon économiste
principal au mouvement desjardins
bonjour monsieur vachon merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui
bon alors est-ce que effectivement les
signaux qu'on a vu cette semaine cette
dent 6 qui était vraiment très
importante
est-ce que ça doit nous donner une leçon
ou nous envoyer un message clair
l'acclamant il ya des risques
est-ce qu'on va vraiment la récession à
court terme on l'est pas encore
convaincu d'ailleurs les grandes banques
font des prévisions ont rencontré un peu
un scénario de base l'indic dont 120 en
récession mais il ya certainement des
risques uhlans que la confiance diminue
la volatilité des marchés le risque d'
escalade des tensions commerciales c'est
tout des risques s'accumulent qui
pourraient éventuellement conduire une
récession voilà on voit que c'est depuis
qu'il y à ces négociations très
difficiles entre washington et pékin
quand on voit les marchés finalement
être ébranlée de jour en jour selon
qu'on annonce des tarifs supplémentaires
au cours l'erreur s'il est ce que vous
croyez que cette incertitude là il ya
certains groupes qui en tire avantage
est ce que c'est un plaisir à certains
groupes suisses comme un peu un bras de
fer états unis la chine puis
possiblement quatre heures mais en
voyant lâché l'économie chinoise faiblit
comme c'est le cas actuellement il peut
avoir l'impression ça donne peut-être
certains avantages dont il y avait le
plus gros bout du bâton tire profit de
boisséson qui ont fait un peu plus en
plus ça dure plus que maintenant la
chine pourrait céder maccoll s'arrêtera
pari risqué sur la chaîne a quand même
une grosse économie quand même un
certain potentiel de pour avoir des
pauvres des mesures de petites mesures
de représailles vide économie américaine
dont le but
à quelques semaines de son passé pour la
dévaluation de sa monnaie et pour air
liquide et ses actifs qui détient en
dollars américains et quand même par les
mesures des contre-mesures il préfère
mal aussi aux états unis donc ça peut
être un jeu dangereux pour les la
communauté internationale les marchés
vont passer d'un bonnet ils donc cesser
cette guerre comment ces tensions
commerciales entre ces deux super
puissances
est ce que vous sentez enfin les
entreprises une certaine réticence à
aller plus loin à investir ou à produire
plus où tu as dont les d'établir des
contacts pour conclure des marchés
présentant cse un peu partout dans le
monde des entreprises sont plus distants
10 idées on voit investi d'un pays mais
peut-être que dans une année l'axé ce
bilan va être plus compliqué ils voient
des barrières tarifaires faire en sorte
que finalement ça sera pas aussi
longtemps que je pensais cet
investissement la danse c'est ce que des
investissements qui sont reportés
présentement on vous sent les indices de
confiance des entreprises ont beaucoup
diminué un peu partout dans le monde
beaucoup de secteurs manufacturiers l'on
vaut si même le service commence à
vouloir suivre manufacturier donc c'est
là que ça devient un peu plus inquiétant
dont certainement il ya environ ça
s'appellerait présent maintenant oui
monsieur prix encore très forte escalade
des tarifs de manière concrète on va
quand même sur la confiance ça a pas
besoin est ce qu'une entente entre les
états unis et pékin permettrait d'éviter
de récession certaines ça permettrait de
réduire les risques
mais faut pas oublier que ça fait plus
de dix ans que les états unis ont pas
connu de récession
éventuellement on va en avoir eu l
accord avec l ordre de grandeur à savoir
qu'il y en a plusieurs d'une récession
par définition c'est juste des deux
trimestres où la production totale d'une
économie diminue si juste de deux
trimestres que ça diminue très
légèrement peut-être qu'il reprenne si
grosse a fait ce chômage constitue une
récession c'est l'effet ce chômage c'est
celle à claude raynal et mon propos des
récents que le chômage augmente peu dans
ce colis seront pas dans une récession
technique une petite récession mais sont
vos neurones plus grosse récession
et puis même avec des tarifs ou le
safran mais un effet à la hausse sur les
prix donc comparer de stagflation à la
fois de chômage à la fois des certaines
pressions inflationnistes ne s'est pas
de scénario rose bonbon ce cas quel
point l'économie est ébranlée lorsqu'on
a affaire soit à une récession radicales
comme on l'a vu en 2008 ou encore à une
récession en douceur comme celle que on
pourrait envisager s'il y avait une
entente entre la chine et l'asean rsa ce
générateur terrain diminué considérable
le risque de forte récession c'est
certainement une récession comme en 2008
2009 le stock en minerais sont
importants on est appelé la grande
récession si je comptais pas loin d'une
dépression donc de cibler le système
financier qui était en péril la cette
fois ci c'est un financier stable plus
solide peut-être en europe certaines
poches de faiblesse ou d'un point de vue
international se serait pas la même
dynamique
on parle beaucoup de la chine et des
états unis quoi d'autre de bretton
surveiller pour savoir si on se dirige
véritablement vers une récession baisse
continue des taux sur le jour les
différentes données économiques cette
semaine on a vu la prose explique
inquiété les marchés la baisse de la
production industrielle en chine aussi
en allemagne qu'on a vu le pib a diminué
cox est attendu en italie ses besoins
élections'' l'italie voire la session
aussi l'allemagne en colis de 2,2 ce
pilier sur toit de l'europe en récession
le break 6 qui procède et des
turbulences sur les marchés
maintenant on va sauver tout ce qui se
passe dans les pays émergents on voit en
argentine au brésil le mexique des
inquiétudes d'ong et plusieurs ados trop
surveillé mais la tempête parfaite
faudrait qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'éléments est-ce qu'on peut se prémunir
contre une récession là tant que
consommateur investisseurs mais ce qui
est vrai cette fois ci n'ont pas
beaucoup de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
donc beaucoup posément de postes vacants
donc ils vont sûrement qu'on aurait une
récession cependant les postes vacants
qui vont diminuer beaucoup avant qu'elle
ait vraiment des partenaires du sud
emploi non ça donnerait une marge de
manoeuvre une bonne nouvelle pour les
travailleurs dans l'éventuelle on arrête
de récession une petite récession pour
ma probablement qu'on n'aurait pas si
gros effets sur le taux de chômage aussi
de regarder les faits sur les taux
d'intérêt généralement un taux d'intérêt
diminuent dans une récession parce que
l'inflation est plus basse par contre le
son arène gamme tarifaire
peut-être que peut avoir des pressions
inflationnistes ne s'est pas claqué taux
d'intérêt diminuerait peut-être qu'ils
pouvaient remonter le ce serait plus
dommageable à sa seconde hypothèque qui
verrait les le taux de mentir ou baisser
comme la tendance est présentement ça
pourrait changer la donne mais pour
certains donc prendre beaucoup de
chômage un peu des hausses de taux ne
serait pas la meilleure situation la
poule pour lier
les propriétaires parfois comprendre les
choses ça nous permet d'être moins
inquiet merci d'avoir été avec nous pour
nous expliquer tout ça mais ma chance ça
fait plaisir au revoir